this is a production of Cornell
University
so today I am going to be talking about
my work on genomics of insect and
nematode pathogens and I thought I would
start out broadly just introducing the
where do we find in sec pathogens in the
fungi and there's really two and two
three or three major groups the or belay
leaves which are these are these are
ascomycete fungi this is a phylogeny of
the ascomycota and in the orbit lilies
we have a lot of nematode trapping fungi
so these are these organisms that live
in soil their infamous for forming these
lassies that capture and actively trap
nematodes in soil another big group of
in particularly the insect pathogens are
in the sir dario my seeds and
particularly in the order hypo creole
eaves and so here's some charismatic
these are the charismatic fungi growing
out of this is growing out of a I think
it's a silkworm pupa so cordyceps fungus
very brightly colored and then there are
also very various shapes that grow out
of beetles
this is actually to ly palladium
attempted to pronounce growing out of
wood but underneath there is a beetle so
many of these fungi infect wood-boring
beetles for example and so here's here's
a decaying log with twopical a diem
coming out and actually spore you
leading the lab a bony Ally's are not
actually insect pathogens but they are
ectoparasites and they're actually
sexually transmitted so like humans
Roger I have have nutritional make
nutritional choices so this is the hypo
creole as I just wanted to introduce you
to the order because I'm going to be
talking about them quite a bit today and
that's origin right here it includes
organisms like Fusarium I hope everyone
has here in this department has heard
about Fusarium a major pathogen of a lot
of grasses and an other plants
so in green I'm showing the plant
associate
members of hypocretin or their plants a
probes that degrade they also degrade
decaying plant material we can call them
the vegetarians and then at the
transition to the hypo cream so that's
sort of the basil the basil group of the
hypo Creole ease our plant associated
and then as we move to this node in the
phylogeny we have a shift to both
microparasites so micro figgus window
that attack other fungi things like
trichoderma which are used for bio
control and then here we have actually
two independent origins of insect and
nematode pathogens we'll call these the
true meat eaters they actually infect
insects and nematodes and use them as a
food source there they're looking
they're good nitrogen source insects and
nematodes I would say that that life so
this is a very nice tidy story I would
say that real life is a little bit more
complicated and in fact one of the
things that I'm interested in are the
variation in hosts across these fungi so
this this is was a phylogeny done by a
former postdoc in my postdoc lab that
tracks again tracks host associations
green is plant associated blue is fungal
hosts associated and red is insect or
animal associated and you can see there
have been a lot of host shifts within
the hypocracy so these fungi are
commonly shifting hosts from being plant
parasites inside parasites to nematode
parasites to fungal parasites and that's
a very interesting aspect of their
ecology and interestingly there are also
some members even the same strains that
can do both so you've probably heard
about a fungus called meadow rhythm it's
a very commonly known insect pathogen
but it also grows its rises to a
competent and it grows in the
rhizosphere and it has actually also
been shown to be endo FIDIC and so it
has both aspects of this lifestyle in
its ecology similarly bavaria bastiana
a very good wide hoe strange insect
pathogen also colonizes plants as an end
of fight and so one of the things I'm
interested in is this dual aspects of
the ecology of these fungi so today I'm
going to tell you a few stories about
some different projects that I'm working
on the first is really a file of genomic
analysis of the order hypo crazy
looking at changes in primary metabolism
and how those might shift at this change
or transition from the plant associated
host to insect or make a parasitic host
that I'm going to tell you a little bit
about tell a palladium inflate them
particularly oxidative enzymes and
secondary the role of oxidative enzymes
and secondary metabolites in insect
pathogenesis and that a project I have
working on beginning working on Bavaria
bastiana which is an insect pathogen and
we're looking at really trying to look
at interest specific genetic diversity
in this in this species in terms of
secondary metabolite potential what what
can what can these fungi produced and
how does that affect their virulence or
their ecology and finally end with some
work on nematode parasites that that I
have a project working on so so you
think about primary metabolism
associated with the transition from
plant to insect nutritional nodes or
host we actually need to think about
some of the carbon sources and nitrogen
sources that these fungi might encounter
on both of those hosts so in plants
obviously we have cellulose lignin
pectin Hemi cellulose all these things
are things that a fungus might need to
be able to digest
whereas in fungal parasites and insect
parasites we oftentimes have chitin as
the primary polymer of the cell wall of
fungi and also cuticle of insects and so
that's just to kind of summarize the
barriers that a fungus might find to to
attack a plant versus an insect so
in a plant we have an outer protective
layer composed of wax cute and cute Ain
in an insect we also have what's called
the EPI cuticle which in fact is a
little bit of a waxy layer as well
it contains actually has some long-chain
hydrocarbons or alkane compounds as well
as fatty acids polyphenols and slur to
noise protein so that's really the first
barrier for a plant pathogen versus an
insect pathogen and then in actual cell
wall we have cellulose hemicellulose
pectin versus protein and chitin in an
insect cuticle and then once inside a
host we actually have some very similar
challenges being able to grow in a very
nutrient limited environment inside the
host being able to evade the immune
system of both a plant and an insect and
also being able to survive oxidative
stress which is a component of the
defense response of both plants and
insects so when we think about gene
families so this was really a file a
genomic approach and this was in
collaboration with some a group in China
actually at the Chinese Academy of
Science and Joey Spadafora and we're
looking at the evolution of several gene
families involved integrating some of
these compounds across the hypo creel
ease and we think about carbon degrading
enzymes we think about chasms or
carbohydrate active enzymes and we have
glycosyl hydrolases which include most
of the cellulases and other other
enzymes of degrading cellulose by costal
transferases polysaccharide lyases so
these and particularly talking about
pectin degradation which is the glue
that holds together plant cells and then
carbohydrate s trace and carbohydrate
binding modules in terms of oxidative
enzymes we have p4 cytochrome p450s and
protease is actually play a very
important role in insect pathogenesis in
degrading the outer cuticle of the
so when we look at the evolution of
chasm families across this is the order
hypo creole ease again starting right
here at this point and then we have at
this point here we have a shift to
either insect in red parasitism or
fungal in in blue and so we've been
looking at how do the enzymes that
degrade the components of points of all
versus the components of insect cuticle
and fungal cell walls how does how does
that change within a genome and we do
see a decrease among a shift here in a
general decrease in overall numbers of
chasms in both the fungal and the insect
pathogens and when we look specifically
at you know breaking down these families
of chasms in particular we have a very
so here again we see a decrease in
really all families particularly like ah
so hydrous hydrolases
and fobbed in cellulose degradation and
poli-sci polysaccharide lyases in
particular I mean we talk about those
that degrade pectin but you can see here
the animal matter is iam tulip radium
and cordyceps really only have three
whereas most of our plant pathogens have
numbers in the 20s to 30s and this is
just to show you in terms of pectin
catabolism when we look at the actual
pathway from degrading pectin to pecked
a 2d Gallic Turin ate these are the
enzyme commission codes involved and
when we map that across this group in
terms of their ecology so plant plant
associate in green fungal in blue and
red insect pathogens you can see there
is in fact a significant contraction of
these of this enzyme family at this
transition to insect pathogenesis these
fungi no longer need these enzymes in
terms of oxidative enzymes the
cytochrome p450s I'm sure most of you
are familiar with them but I thought I'd
just briefly describe them there
oxidative enzymes that use a heme
cofactor and they're involved in
oxidation of various organic substrates
so lipids steroids xenobiotics or
foreign compounds and they interestingly
are also involved in the synthesis of
secondary metabolites and they're
generally classified based on sequence
similarity in two families based on 40%
amino acid similarity and Sutton so this
would be the family sip 561 and
subfamilies based on 55% amino acid
identity so subfamily c and then an
individual class or gene would be given
a number across the we look at oxidative
enzymes across this group we also see an
increase in the plant pathogenic group
and a decrease in Toula palladium and
cordyceps in the insect pathogens in
particular and i didn't mention this
this is actually a cafe analysis so
we've we've looked at the extent numbers
in current species and then using
maximum likelihood inferred ancestral
numbers at each of these nodes and then
inferred increases at particular nodes
or decreases at particular nodes
proteases we also see a similar pattern
I guess I I didn't actually point out
here that in the meta regime group we do
actually see an increase in oxidative
enzymes and remember that I said
mannerism is actually one of these fungi
that has a dual ecology in terms of
being able to colonize both the res fear
and the roots and also being a good
insect pathogen so interestingly they
have retained some of these enzymes that
may be important for plant colonization
in terms of proteases we also see a
similar pattern increasing in plant
associated and also in the meta rhythm
clade and then a decrease a decrease
both in the fungal parasites and also in
the insect parasites or pathogens
so in conclusion from this part of the
talk when we look at widely across the
order and across fungi with different
Ecology's we do see a expansions in
plant or I guess they could be either
expansions in the plant associated fungi
or contractions particularly in the
insect associated fungi and particularly
those genes involved in cellulose and
pectin degradation insect pathogens have
pretty much lost the function of
degrading cellulose and pectin people
are 50s in proteases so a similar
expansion in the plan associated fungi
and and in those fungi that have a dual
ecology they are able they also show a
similar or more broad profile of both of
these classes of enzymes than the true
and strict insect pathogens okay so so
now I'm gonna move on to talk a little
bit about my work until a palladium
inflate them this is a mouthful to light
palladium it's Latham and this is it's a
widespread soil fungus in fact it was
thought to be asexual until Cathy Hodge
from this department this is a
photograph from the plant path herbarium
discovered the sexual stage of to lipo
Collegium so we thought we thought it
was an anamorphic fungus living in soil
but in fact it infects beetles it was
first discovered on a scarab beetle here
in Ithaca New York interesting and
here's what's left of the beetle right
here sadly it's infected the beetle and
it's grown this is the stroma
of the fungus so it's formed a fruiting
body and up here it's forming sexual
spores and para theseare so and this is
this is actually what you're looking at
before in that picture with it coming
out of the root of the wood it's
actually growing through the wood and
then going out into the air just for you
late and spread its force it is also
well known or most known in
rest of the world and nobody knows what
to lipo clean him inflate them is but
how many of you have heard of the drug
cyclosporine only a few of you it's good
I guess none of you have had organ
transplants so that's a good thing so
it's it's not well known in the medical
world for being the producer of an
immunosuppressant drug called
cyclosporine a and cyclosporine a is the
product of a non-ribosomal peptide
synthesis gene which su Lee mentioned I
studied for my PhD and it's a it's an 11
modular gene that forms an 11 amino acid
or peptide ring cyclic structure and it
really was that the compound that was
responsible for development of
successful organ transplantation there's
actually at the University of Minnesota
Medical Center there's a there's a
little picture of topical adium on the
mural real a while I was riding up the
escalator one day and I saw that's it
has in fact made very important
contributions to medicine before that we
had a real issue with organ rejection
and and now most organ transplant
patients take cyclosporine it's also
used to treat a number of other
autoimmune disorders like rheumatoid
arthritis and psoriasis actually um so
here's just a better diagram of the
lifecycle of t'lie palladium and like a
plant pathogen it has to infect its host
and interestingly does that also by
forming a form of a purse Oriya and kind
of trading through the insect cuticle so
here's a - hi feet penetrating inside
cuticles so this I'm going to call the
host infection stage once inside an
insect
many of these insect pathogenic fungi
undergo and also human pathogenic fungi
undergo a dimorphic switch so they
change from a Highfill stage to a yeast
stage in order to proliferate throughout
the insect Hema seal and so they
proliferate eventually causing death and
then sporulation
on the insect so here's this is a this
is a live weevil and on the
right here is a deadly bowl with till a
palladium sporulating and this is also a
mechanism to spread spores to new
insects if so we now know from the
genome that Philippa caladium inflate M
is a hetero phthalic fungus it has two
mating types and so only if we get two
mating types infecting the same insect
can we have mating and production of the
sexual state and sexual spores and it's
thought that both ascospores and the
comitia can infect an insect although
there hasn't been a lot of study on
which is more important in nature so so
one of the studies that I've done is an
RNA seek experiment to look at some of
the mechanisms of insect pathogenesis
and I started out I was afraid to work
inside an insect this was my first foray
into the insect world and so I decided
to grow the fungus in a media a minimal
media containing insect cuticle added so
it actually dissected some some weebles
the cuticle and treated that and put it
in the media and then isolated and
hemolymph and put that in the media and
then collected RNA and did RNA seek and
looking for responses to those two media
and I'm going to talk a little bit I'm
sure many of you are also familiar with
the go ontology where we're looking at
trying to classify genes I find it a
very useful way to classify functions of
genes and talk broadly about
transcriptional responses to particular
condition and so the top layer we have
again solely on the cellular location or
component of a gene or protein
biological process what general broad
process is involved with and molecular
function specific enzymatic functions
and these are again hierarchical so we
move from very general to very specific
and so when we do so this is when we do
a network look at overexpressed and up
the sir these are the up regulated genes
from the cuticle media
and these are mapped to the genome of
tilapia lady and protein genome and then
looking at we're looking at
over-represented gene over-represented
categories of go and so what we do find
is that Syrian peptidases and Syrian
hydrolases which have been pretty well
characterized as being involved in
penetrating or digesting the cuticle
were one class that's up regulated then
we have genes in oxido reductase
activity and siderophore iron transport
and so this is gonna become a theme for
today's talk I decided to look
particularly at cytochrome p450s and
interestingly there are a number from
this six five five family and set 505
family and these have been actually
studied in Bavaria ba Siana and shown to
degrade out paints and also an alkane
assimilation and this is a fatty acid
hydroxylase and this one is involved in
degradation of oleic acid and in there
was a really nice paper that came out in
Bavaria that showed that several members
of this class of cytochrome p450s do you
actually can actually degrade some of
the particular hydrocarbons so the
hydrocarbon compounds found in insect
cuticle and so that's very likely their
role and and Families 655 and 505 when
we look at the genes upregulated in
hemolymph
we again see importance of iron binding
and oxido reductase activity and then a
large category of genes involved in
sugar and carbohydrate transmembrane
transport which I still don't really
understand what they're involved in but
we're we're looking into that and in
terms of the cytochrome p450 family
there are a couple interesting genes
this this one right here these both of
these from
current families and actually from the
same family 504 are involved in ortho
hydroxylation of phenyl acetate and
phenyl acetate is one one compound that
is produced by the insect immune
response and so these two genes could be
involved in detox inside inside of an
insect so that's another potential
function of the cytochrome p450s so
that's sort of more primary different
changes in primary metabolism and ways
to utilize an insect versus a plant host
and now i'm going to move on to my
favorite topic
fungal secondary metabolites genes and
I'm sure you've heard from Gillian a
little bit about categories of secondary
metabolites genes but there are
non-ribosomal peptide synthesis or NRP
s's poly key tights and faces or PKS
a--'s terpene synthases which produced
her pains and isoprenoids and dimethyl
al l-tryptophan synthesis which are
involved in the first synthesis step of
many alkaloids or got alkaloid and
alkaloid compounds and you've also
probably heard that n RP SS are modular
both and RPS SNP cases are modular in
the sense that they're comprised of
protein domains that string together
amino acids non-ribosomal e and link
them into a small peptide similarly in
poly key types and faces we have
linkages of carbon molecules usually
acetal or malonyl co a feather feature
of secondary metabolite gene clusters on
a fungi is that in most one jaya cluster
many of the genes involved in production
of a particular metabolite into a
secondary metabolite cluster and this is
a cluster for cyclosporine synthetase
from to let palladium and you can see
that it actually contains both an N R PS
and a PKS gene as well as a large number
of other kinds of accessory proteins
that may be involved in transport
modification oxidation or set elation of
the final product
um we do know a fair amount about I just
wanted to briefly talk about some of the
secondary metabolites that we have we
know about from the hypo Creoles um
few Manas ins from Fusarium and niacin
are both well few mana since in
particular important for plant
pathogenesis peptide balls are an
interesting group from the Trichoderma
that these are large and RPS produced
compounds that form pores in membranes
and then you have a lot of compounds
that have shown some effect in terms of
being involved in insect pathogenesis so
the very soon basi on allied from
Bavaria species they've been knocked out
and shown to have a roll in and they're
not pathogenicity factors but they have
a role in insect pathogenesis and then
the ergot alkaloids in para mean from a
Chloe species are really thought to be
anti feeding compounds they interfere or
they deter or bits one of their
functions but we also know that the
ergot alkaloids obviously have
neurological effects but I'm sure you've
heard about some of those and then
finally down here we have destructions
from meta resume and cyclosporine sperm
to lipo caladium which have effects on
the insect immune response their immune
suppressants generally and this has been
well shown for cyclosporine in insects
so this is controlled and this is a
cyclosporine treated you can see that
this is production I believe proactive
it might be anti bacterial peptides or
lysosomes so there's a really strong
effect of cyclosporine on the insect
immune response and based on that we now
know that cyclosporine also interferes
with the human immune response binding
to interfering with calcineurin
activating nuclear factors and the
initiation of transcription of
interleukin 2 so when I looked at the
expression of sight the cyclosporine
cluster
in both of these different kinds of
media so the cuticle media and the
hemolymph media it was expressed in both
and this was also very useful in
defining what genes were actually within
the cluster and involved in biosynthesis
so these are these are all these two are
computational prediction programs for
defining a secondary metabolite cluster
and we actually did RNA sync we found
that it was actually a combination of
those two we found the intersection that
is very likely the set of genes involved
in production but it does actually look
like cyclosporine is more highly up
regulated in the hemolymph media which
makes sense it's probably active once
the fungus has penetrated and it's in
the Hema so it's trying to kill an
insect suppress suppress the immune
system um if I would add in I told you
Lee and I was gonna add in a slide about
iron metabolism and iron secondary
metabolites and actually this is
something I worked on for my PhD Gillian
and Gillian had determined that there
were really two different pathways of
production of sedara fungal siderophores
one leads to intracellular crime type
siderophores the other to extracellular
Sedaris a
and RPS called n RPS six in cochlea
bolus and for my PhD I actually wrote a
paper on the the fact that there are
paralogs of these genes in many in
several fungi there's a there's a there
was a gene duplication event and some
fungi including till I poked ledian
actually have two copies so they have a
copy from this group that is homologous
to the cochlea dualists and PS six ed
which form compounds known as copper
genes and also have a copy homologous to
a gene in a human pathogen Aspergillus
fumigatus and this is known as sodi and
it produced and also in feed areum which
it produces a tri-c diffuser and seek
type compound so we're interested in why
doesn't a lipo caladium have to and we
still don't fully know the answer but
when we look at its patterns of
expression we do find that the Cobra Jen
type is more highly expressed in a
cuticle media whereas the Aspergillus
homolog is more highly expressed in a
hemolymph media and it has been shown
that the Aspergillus homolog is involved
in human pathogenesis so it makes sense
that that the tell a palladium homolog
may have may also have a function in
insect pathogenesis okay so so this work
really identified some particular gene
families that we are investigating to
look at their roles and insect
pathogenesis so oxidated particularly
oxidative enzymes and those involved in
response to oxidative stress serine
proteases involved in penetrating the
insect cuticle and then iron scavenging
and binding molecules which clearly have
been shown to have roles in both plant
and animal pathogenesis clearly also had
roles in insect pathogenesis and in
terms of secondary metabolites
cyclosporine is the one that I'm
continuing to work on and really trying
to nail down we're doing some gene
knockouts and tagging at the moment I
don't have any results to report from
that yet but we're really interested in
what is it doing inside of an insect and
what is its target because we actually
although we know the target in humans we
don't actually know the target in
insects funny how that works and then
siderophores iron scavenging is clearly
important okay so now I'm going to tell
you a little bit about a project that
we're working on in Bavaria bossy onna
and this was actually really initiated
by a high school student that came to me
one day and said I'd like to do a
science project in your lab or for a
something known as the Intel Science
Fair it's a nationwide competition for
high school students and I said oh okay
and he did an amazing amount of work he
was an incredible undergrad he actually
had completed a math degree at the
to Minnesota by the end of his high
school degree and is now in an MD MBA MD
program at the University of Minnesota
so he was a special high school student
and you did a lot of transcriptomic work
and then two postdocs I have also worked
on it
John minke was my first postdoc he did a
lot of genomics work and Radhika Bajaj
did a lot of insect infection assays and
some followed up on some of the
transcript omics so I better introduce
Bob area area as I mentioned is best
known as as an insect pathogen it is
actually one one strain is a component
of a bio control product known as this
is my control oh actually I think there
are two bio control products out on the
market and here is an insect spray it
can be sprayed on foliage and will kill
insect pests effective but recently it's
also been discovered as a systemic end
of fight and it grows both in the roots
so this is a gfp strain and they showed
that it this is um roots and met iridium
and bavaria both grow in the roots where
sub area is also growing in the leaves
but matter is iam is not Bavaria is also
a huge very bossy Jana in particular is
a huge species complex and we still know
very little about the phylogenetic or
the population structure or potentially
phylogenetic structure of this group and
they're distributed worldwide and you
know many of the we also invited over a
little about differences in virulence
and how do we go about selecting a good
bio control stream and so this is
actually a collaboration with dr. Steve
Rayner at the USDA in Beltsville he has
a enormous collection of the various
strains and been working a little bit
with him on that
and initially we've just started
sequencing about 10 genomes and this was
done using Illumina technology and we
did three out-group taxa but very
bassiano
broken RTI Australis and
see Attica I guess four and then eight
different strains of Bavaria ba Siena
and it's a fairly small genome with very
low repeat content so these were fairly
easy to assemble to a good quality draft
genome and have very little very low
repeat content they're nice fungus and
specifically when we look at interest
but one of our interest is to look at
interest specific diversity of secondary
metabolite genes and when we look across
so these are the different categories of
secondary metabolite genes on the top
here and these are all the different
strains and there is variation and
really a lot of them in particular the
polyketide synthase genes show high
variation as well as terpene synthase
genes however when we look at the genes
that we know have some function in
insect pathogenesis we don't see much
variation we just embarrassing for
example is present in all all of the
bavaria bossy honest strains bossy
analyte is present in all but one and
tunnel in which is a an RPS PKS hybrid
produced compound is also present in all
that one so there's not a lot of
divergence in terms of the entropy s
genes that we know are involved in
insect pathogenesis but we when we look
at both poly key types and faces and
terpenes and phases we do see a lot more
interest specific variation and this is
just a comparison of six strains and on
the bottom here is the number of strains
that share so two strains share six
genes there's actually about 25
different PKS genes and only four of
them are shared across all these strains
and so there's really a lot of
specialization and strain specific
secondary metabolite genes the same is
true of terpenes although there are less
there's only four or five terpene
synthase genes and these fungi but but
there's also variable numbers and we
found an interesting terpene cluster
that we're now following up on where we
actually see a complete duplication or
loss of the entire gene cluster
so this is a large gene cluster probably
about 45 kilobases and it is absent in
the ancestral out-group species so it
appears to have originated at the origin
in the Bavaria bassiano species complex
and it's been lost in one stream and
duplicated in another strain and when we
look at very lens we've also done some
virulence assays Bavaria on an insect so
we're using we're actually using
lepidopteran the fall army worm our
spinatra fruit papaya and we're using
injections we want to make sure
interestingly Bavaria did not colonize
the cuticle very well this particular
insect which was interesting to me so we
decided to go with an injection it's
also a much more exact approach to
inject a certain amount of spores into
an insect and then we also grow control
in a liquid media minimal liquid and
also PDB and then at 24 and 48 hours
harvested
actually the whole insects and the
tissue from the fungus to do RNA seek
and also look at the time to death and
just for you layin and ld50 and when we
look at a survival curve we had a few
this our control we had a few losses and
then we had this one in the middle which
actually corresponds I believe 2 3 4 0
but there's really two two groups we
have the control and there's a couple in
the middle and then very strongly
virulent but but when we look at we
compare those two streams 3 4 0 where we
have a complete loss of the cluster and
318 where we have a duplication of the
cluster we do see a really strong effect
on virulence at day 7 in 3 4 0 90% of
those insects are dead in 3 18 only 8 or
I'm sorry 90% are alive and in 3 18 only
18 percent of our lives so it's a much
quicker time to death which is a which
is a measure of virulence
and so we're now kind of following up on
this we're doing some gene knockouts at
the moment to really try to characterize
does this have a specific role in insect
pathogenesis and what what is that again
when we look at expression and this is a
we didn't actually see much much change
at 24 hours but when we look at 48 hours
after injection and we both see
initiation of an insect immune response
and we also see turning on a fungal
genes and again we have genes involved
in oxidation oxidative activity in this
case we also have genes involved in
fatty acid biosynthesis which which is
interesting fatty acids are becoming
shown to be important in various
signaling processes and that's so this
is general biological processes and then
in terms of molecular function again we
have oxido reductase activities metal
binding in particular iron comes out of
that as well so so these two categories
are clearly important in insect
pathogenesis and then we also have holo
acyl carrier protein synthesis activity
and if you know many of the secondary
metabolites actually use an acyl carrier
protein mode of action to attach amino
acids to the N RPS protein we've also
found some interesting candidate
secondary metabolites there's a PKS that
appears to be homologous to lovastatin
biosynthesis cluster and in RPS gene a
fatty acid synthase gene and also three
acyl adenylate ensigns which are really
just the one domain of an n RP s protein
so in conclusion it's clear that
variation in the secondary metabolite n
chalene for confer important differences
in phenotype particularly virulence
in an insect and we're really working
right now in doing some of the genetics
so we believe now how the gene knockout
of the
synthase and also some chemistry to
really nail down what what is this thing
producing and what might be its effect
on the insect immune system okay a few
more one for a few more slides this is
this is a tail the tail of my story so I
also have a project working on nematode
pathogens and parasites and a big a
large part of that is actually
collecting we've been collecting a large
number of fungi from agricultural fields
so a soybean corn rotation in Minnesota
which is pretty much all you see in
Minnesota soybean or corn field so we
collected them from this is actually the
soybean cyst nematode so we've collected
them from eggs the soybean cyst nematode
from soil from soybean roots and various
environments and then the final it's
part of this project just to look at
mechanisms of virulence and also toxins
that might be produced by some of these
fungi and this was worked by a master
student um and he's still actually
working on this and he was interested in
comparing several different nematode
parasites so one that's a trapping
fungus are about religious flora an egg
parasite metaphor cordyceps clone is
phoria and a j2 parasite so this is a j2
is a worm stage of the nematode it's
actually the infective stage of a root
and this is her sutala minnesotan cysts
isolated from minnesota and so here's
interested in and looking at what are
their similarities or differences
between the way that these different
nematode parasites interact with a
nematode and he did clustering on the
genome level so there's no ala Guster's
gene families across the three pathogens
and found that there's more similarities
between meta cordyceps and each of these
other fungi so lots of shared genes then
between the JT parasite and the trapping
fungus
and then he also did an RNA seek
experiment where he grew up the fungus
and we decided to use liquid culture
just to get enough tissue to do RNA
analysis but we added either so for the
j2 or worm parasites we added a co
culture of sterilized worms and for the
egg parasite we added sterilized eggs
and then collected RNA samples at day
one three and seven and again when we
look at so this is an early interaction
at 24 hours and we're excited to see
something related to chemical stimuli
when at one of the things that were
interested in in these nematode
parasites is you know are their signals
that we are their chemical signals
either from the plant or from the fungus
or from other nematodes that we could
utilize for bio control and so we're
looking into some of the genes in this
category and also this category of
response to miss folded proteins or some
heat shock proteins which we are not
clear what those are those are doing and
again when we look at molecular function
we also see oxido reductase activity and
iron binding and also carbohydrate
kinase activity which I also have no
idea what that is involved in at the
moment and so when he compared so this
is looking again at the early response
when he compared up regulated genes and
looked at ornithologist clusters of
those again there are more similarities
between meta cordyceps in each of these
other fungi than between the two and he
also identified a group of what we call
core ornithologist clusters that might
have a shared common common role in
nematode pathogenesis and some of those
categories are in fact heat shock
proteins these ones we we don't know
what they are so we're goes and then so
another category that has some secondary
metabolite genes in it there's actually
an interesting PKS gene in this cluster
24 that may have a role in in nematode
pathogenesis
um so in in conclusion um it's clear
that there are some shared mechanisms of
pathogenesis across different nematode
parasites and even insect Capuchin so
these are actually very closely related
fungi and it may not be that much of a
shift to move from an insect to a
nematode ecology
there are many shared and enzyme
families that are involved in
pathogenesis and we've also identified
some interesting secondary metabolites
candidate genes that we're now working
on some genetic approaches to fully
characterize their functions and so with
that I will thank some people people and
most of our genomics work has been done
at both the Mayo Clinic and the
Minnesota biochemical biogenetic and
topical ADM was actually sequenced at
Duke University with funding from an
interesting source a mushroom production
company in Korea interested in trying to
understand how these fungi fruit in
fruiting genes the mating type genes
most of the tilapia caladium genome and
transcriptome is done in collaboration
with Joey status for his lab at Oregon
State and the bavaria project i'm been
working with steve rainer at the usda
and then these postdocs and outstanding
high school students and funding that's
mostly funded right now through the
university of minnesota and then this
comparative work on the Geno genomics
and toxin production of nematode
parasites is sort of synergistic with
the project that we have with from the
USDA identifying name is herd parasites
and pathogens for potential bio control
or bio pesticide use and also a little
bit of funding from the Minnesota
soybean growers if you're in Minnesota
it's good to get funding from the
Minnesota soybean and so with that I
mean thank you and happy to take any
questions
[Applause]
good question we're still looking at
that question we're now moving on so
we've done the insect pathogenicity
essays we're actually going to do some
plant pathogen escy assays and assess
that and then we are going to address
that question I think and there's
actually a another graduate student
she's actually co-advised who's doing an
experimental evolution project so she's
looking at if I passage it through an
insect multiple times how does the
genome change if I passage it through a
plant multiple times how does the genome
change so that that will actually be
very interesting I think questions very
interested so what's the plan I'm doing
all this kind of genome work is that for
both reasons for you know the
bioindustry because I'm very curious of
what the infected insect fungus is doing
because a lot of people are interested
in that for all host of like you know
energy powering or viagra or because I
was at a professor that was working in
Nepal on roads and he said that there's
a lot of people collecting worms in
Nepal and selling them to China and for
the that infected the way you're saying
used for Viagra reasons
and probably for other reasons so I was
just curious yeah I mean I think I think
there are a lot of potential
applications to this work I mean my my
work with the Minnesota soybean growers
is really an agricultural application
can we find biopesticides can we find an
organism that we could use for bio
control um but I've actually been a
mission I was in China for a year so I
actually studied this fungus that grows
in Nepal in China and that that is
clearly a medicinal use and I think you
know looking at - like palladium also um
there's clearly medical things that we
have not discovered from these fungi
they're there and Stewart is working on
this there you know there are compounds
that we have no idea that exists and
these fungi so I think it's the time
it's an untapped resource I think they
become more susceptible to infection I
mean if you treat it with cyclosporine
retreated pretreated
yeah we haven't actually done that
experiment like that that would be
interesting to do I think thank you this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu